à chambord en été pour visiter le
château de françois 1er
il faut un peu patienter à l'entrée
beaucoup de monde
la file d'attenté même plutôt longue ce
père de famille est venue de touraine
c'est la deuxième fois qu'il visite le
château des fois vous et que par rapport
à la dernière fois nous sommes venus il
ya énormément de monde à la dernière
fois on était venu un peu hors saison
effectivement on était rentrés très
fascinant on avait pu réaliser la visite
en toute tranquillité est là aujourd'hui
il ya quand même beaucoup plus de monde
beaucoup de monde
certes mais à chambord les responsables
sont contents le premier semestre a été
plutôt bon en terme de fréquentation +
2,75 pour cent
seul petit bémol le mois de juillet qui
enregistre une légère baisse sans doute
plusieurs effets il ya peut-être la
canicule qui joue quand il fait très
chaud les gens bougent mois il ya
peut-être eu l'effet de la coupe du
monde aussi
et puis bah il ya quatre cinq mille 2,5
en juillet donc le mois de juillet est
pas tout à fait comparable
on observe aussi que il y à une sorte de
déplacement de la haute saison vers le
mois d'août le mois d'août est beaucoup
plus important maintenant que juillet le
mois de septembre
comment être plus important aussi que le
mois de juillet vérification aujourd'hui
le mois d'août est en effet plutôt bien
parti avec par exemple beaucoup de
touristes sur les terrasses pour admirer
les jardins à la française
c'est vrai que c'est sympa on voit les
jardins sert aux magnifiques 1 vous êtes
venu d'antibes exprès en partie pour
connaître un peu la région et alors vous
il ya du monde c'est facile à visiter en
plein est et comment pour l'instant ça
va ça se passe bien c'est notre première
journée mais ça se passe bien pour
l'instant
après avoir atteint 1 million de
visiteurs en 2017 les responsables de
chambord espère confirmer ce chiffre
cette année et même le dépasser l'an
prochain à l'occasion des 500 ans du
château